[Music] It's a
short
smash. The transformation is black-blue drive Re-chan. I
picked it up badly even if I chose it. I wasn't attacking from here.
I was too conscious of control I
couldn't swing my arm
ban If
the cause of the slump was
tired again,
I had to make music etc.
I'm also a person with 100 waves, and
if I think that jumping smash hit from the Takaida store is the best weapon
, the people around me have
been tall since I was a big kid, so I'm tall, even if I don't
have a left hand  I
can't pick up the shuttle unless I train my legs more than people because
I have enough weight. I think the reason
you bought it so far is because you've made such efforts. You can
hit the net. You can make the
course a little sweeter.
Your smash is
You can believe in your smash
[Music]
You're just a badminton idiot
Look,
you're drinking
[Music]
many
I've been practicing more than anyone else  Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha